hello and welcome to inside the Oscars
I'm Rachel Smith and today we're gonna
show you another side of the Oscars
let's go see what happens backstage join
us for an exclusive look behind the
curtain and inside the Oscars show and
the Oscar goes to Jennifer Lawrence
thank you very very much I like to thank
the Academy if I can't speak peace out a
winner wins and obviously says their
thank-yous and their speech on stage and
they come off the stage and they have
that feeling of euphoria just you know
stunned disbelief other people are
jumping up and down and talking
everybody like we're like we've known
them for years you have a screamer you
have the person that's shaking so much
you literally are like oh door drop the
Oscar door drop the Oscar the first stop
they have is thank you cam where they
can give additional thank-yous to the
people they might have forgotten you or
didn't have time to think on camera but
I could go crazy thanking people so here
we go I'd like to thank my amazing to
you my entire crew my entire cast rinse
I want to thank the thank you cam is
something that actors take a lot of
Vantage of we had Jeff Bridges there for
over an hour what because you just want
to thank everyone just all all of the
actors
my brother Bo and my sister Cindy that's
like it's the end but it's not next
stuff they have is our archival poster
signing the winners sign a poster that
we keep in our vaults and in our
archives and then we proceeded down
winners walk to the winners lobby the
winners Lobby is where the Academy
archival photo expired so they get a
picture with the presenter general
photos next and general photo our
rafters of some of the most well known
photographers here just walk in and it's
just all these cameras it's like this
isn't the stroke sub stroke side stroke
and then the last stop is the interview
room how's everybody doing like an old
ship you're now an Academy award-winning
screenwriter so it's funny the whole
process could take about an hour so we
just got him through that and get him
back in his seat as soon as possible
it's the warmest most special feeling to
be backstage you know the backstage
feeling surprised me a lot it was really
calm and when somebody came off at the
stage people would genuinely excited
after winning the Academy Awards is
special
just because of the nature of what the
Academy Award of Merit means the sense
of your being part of one of history's
moviemaking moments it's an incredibly
unusual experience knowing that you just
produce something
a billion or so people I have just
watched and knowing that we also became
a part of the great legacy of the Oscars
to see all the backstage action on
Oscars Sunday check out the Oscars
backstage show on the watch ABC app